usama aminu is one of the boys rescued
after gunmen stormed his skull
and abducted hundreds of children he
says he was falling asleep when the
attacks started
i started hearing gunshots then when i
came out there were many people already
outside
we were asked to go back to our hostel
then they said the gunmen were already
in the school
we climbed the school fence but they
asked us to return back we thought they
were soldiers who were trying to protect
us but unfortunately they were not
usama used all his wits to try and
survive
when i decided to run they brought a
knife to slaughter me but i ran away
quickly
i ran into the crowd but they couldn't
get me then i put my clothes upside down
so they could not see me
from there they said they would kill
whoever is trying to escape i then began
to run
climbing one rock to another through a
forest
two days after the attack more than 300
boys are still missing
their parents are desperate
to see that our children our last prayer
is to see that our children are back
that is the only prayer that we are
doing we are sleepless
even this last night we stood up praying
to god to bring our children
criminal gangs in northwest nigeria have
become increasingly brazen
targeting civilians for ransom
counter-terrorism experts say
armed gangs may have stormed the school
to force concessions from the local
government
these are guys that have actually
benefited from
amnesty or some forms of negotiation
in the past with both the katsina
government
and also the zamfara state government
but it's believed that
there's a conflict in terms of agreement
rich between
kazna state government and this bandit
so
it's more like attacking the community
so to like um show
or force the catanastic government into
negotiating with them
nigeria's defense ministry says the
whereabouts of the so-called bandits
is known and the military is trying to
bring the boys back home
safely but there's anger that the
abduction happened at all
nigeria's government put measures to
prevent school abductions
after the armed group boko haram
kidnapped 276 schoolgirls
at chibok in 2014.
six years later more than 100 of the
girls are still missing
the fear for parents in katsina state is
that their sons could suffer the same
fate
barbara angopa al jazeera